welcome to this joint overview and
scrutiny committee meeting
i'm councillor keith welland and i'm
chairing the meeting today
my first of all reminds you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting you may
to speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
and that also
applies to laptops can you turn the can
you turn the volume down on your laptops
as well please
and in addition we will be using the
e-voting for this meeting on the
modern.gov app
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press
may record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public and the press
are not lawfully excluded
thank you so i'll just run through who
is here today
as i say i'm chairing the meeting we
have the members of the joint overview
and scrutiny committee
there
and other offices here are
emily aytak who is the assistant
director assets and
investment
jan robinson who's the deputy monitoring
officer
henriette holloway senior governance
officer
bethany webb who's trainee governance
officer and alicia norman who is
technical research and project officer i
think oh sorry and
yeah melissa melissa evans is also here
um
and she is the director for corporate
resources
and who is this holly holly brett
corporate manager
is this the
council is it the holding company or
the couple of councils companies right
thank you sorry
and i believe now emily um you are the
director of assets and investment is
that correct
thank you
and we also have
uh councillors present councillor dave
busby cabinet member for finance assets
and investment
at baber council
peter gould is cabinet member for assets
in investments mid suffolk district
councillor district council and
we have an apology from councillor
malvesi who is the
director of sifko on behalf of baba
district council and we have councillor
rick mayer is here and he is a director
of sifko on behalf of
the mid-suffolk district council if i
get these right hopefully we also have
representatives of sifko
sir christopher howarth sifco board
chair
helen rumsey who is a partner at nsaw's
and neville pritchard director of
capital markets
jl
so
has everybody know been introduced
yeah we're all good
thank you very much
so
can i now move to the agenda please
um do we have any apologies for absence
please and substitutions thank you chair
we have apologies from council paul
epping young and councillor barry
humphries is substituting and we also
have apologies from councillor robert
lindsey
thank you
have there been any declarations of
pecuniary and non-pecuniary interest by
members
council councillor hinton
uh just to make matters clear mr
chairman just to declare a non-pecuniary
interest in that i'm a director of baber
holdings who of course are
one of the owners of civco right
okay
just to make it clear as well that
monitoring officer has granted
dispensation to all directors and
councillors involved in those holding
companies thank you
thank you very much
um
we're now to receive notification of any
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme are there any
none received chair
thank you very much
we now move on to confirm the minutes of
the meeting held on the 25th of april
2022
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the minutes
if not can i have a proposal counselor
caster and councillor
osborne has seconded thank you very much
we will now conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
everybody voted
yeah
councillor dawson may i take your vote
verbally
oh how's it no
thank you very much so the minutes of
the meeting the 25th of april 2022 have
been confirmed
we now move on to questions by the
public
right thank you very much
we now move on to jos
2 2 capital investment
fund company cifco
capital limited
business trading and performance report
um i'm
suggesting if we do not wish to directly
refer to the confidential papers
we will continue in open session
throughout
i'll move item 12 the resolution to
exclude the public
up to the end of the open session this
is item talk further down so i'll remove
that up for item
seven if the committee decides to go
into closed session to consider any
confidential part of the agenda
so the order of this item will be
introductions by
uh councillors dave busby and peter
gould
we will then have a short presentation
from emily atack and christopher howarth
they'll then be questions from members
so can we start please
uh with councillor dave busby and
councillor peter gould to introduce the
report to the committee
thank you chair um it'll be just me i
understand peter said that he introduced
it last time but they've only got his
word for that anyway i'm delighted to
introduce this report to over the new
scrutiny today which shows that cifco
not only continues to deliver much
needed income to our councils but also
has made a significant profit this year
as a result of the value of the
portfolio growing by some 12 percent
cifco has proved itself to be well
managed and held up well during the
patendemic demonstrating the resilient
and well-balanced nature of the
portfolio
sifko has invested this year to improve
the quality and sustainability
credentials of the portfolio including
the installation of solar panels and is
committed to continuing this further
the councils have benefited from 3.75
million pounds of net income this year
and a total of 9 million
since cifco's formation
all of which can be put into our
services helping our communities to
thrive
the council showed courage and ambition
in creating sifko in the first place
and our faith in the expertise and
prudence of the sifko board is now
paying dividends
i told you it'd be short and sweet
that's it
thank you very much
so can i then introduce emily atack and
i think emily will then introduce
christopher howarth at the appropriate
time for their presentation please
thank you thank you dave i think i'm
going to do the the first few slides and
then i will hand over to emily to uh to
finish it off
um this is a presentation on the cifco
business plan for 22.23
next slide please
and sorry i need to do that as well well
on my side i can see what i'm looking at
uh and i think really the focus of the
um
overview and scrutiny committee is to
look and see if our business plan is
robust and appropriate the next 12
months um whether you have sufficient
confidence in the management of cifco
and you you have quite a lot of the
management of civico here
does the current performance of cifco
deliver good value to the councils and i
hope we'll be able to show you that it
does
are the kpi's appropriate measures of
performance
and does overview and scrutiny support
the proposed changes to the civco
business plan governance in future years
um and the um really a brief update of
where
where circo is at the moment
the
investment phase was completed in march
2021 so this is the first year where we
have
not been investing we've been looking at
the portfolio managing portfolio moving
it forward
and of course the focus and purpose of
cifco is to continue to generate income
and add value where possible this is
something that the income obviously is
very important for our shareholders but
at the same time looking at what we can
do to improve the value is very
important also
and the value of the portfolio has
increased by 12
that was just over 10 million um
according to the knight frank valuation
to 94 million that was of march 2022
which obviously is we're pleased about
um the total net income received by the
councils to date is about 9.25 million
that's since the inception of the
country the company in 2017
and throughout that time we've continued
to make full debt repayments to the
councils
there were times when we were slightly
concerned because of some of the effects
of the pandemic but i'm very pleased to
say been an important focus of the board
please say that we've been able to make
those full debt repayments to the
council i think it's very important
and the the portfolio is a diverse
portfolio of assets um and a diverse uh
range of tenants and that's to mitigate
overexposure to
any particular tenants or sectors
and um now that we've sort of come out
of the pandemic the rental arrears have
been below two percent and so we're
pleased about that this obviously is a
big focus of the board and in terms of
making sure that rent is collected on
time
um we have completed five refurbishments
during 2122
um including works to improve the
sustainability of properties and as
we'll look at that in more detail later
but obviously the properties being let
mainly on full repair and ensuring terms
there's only a certain amount we can do
but it's certainly a very important
focus of the board looking to see what
we can do as far as the sustainability
of the portfolio is concerned we've made
some pretty good strides in that
direction
um the voids remain low at uh it's like
a two percent of the portfolio
um the purpose of the business plan um
is to uh
look back monitor the performance of
civco capital over the previous
financial year um
provide a framework and guidance for
investment and management
moving forward it's always an important
part of the company's governance and
we as directors are accountable against
delivery of the business plan
so just having a very quick look at the
um investment market and we do have
neville pritchard of jones lang here so
who will be able to give some probably
much more detailed information if people
have questions later on um as we all
know inflation on is on the rise um
really very significantly on the rise um
interest rates have been rising um but
it is a it's an it's a it's a strange
market because it's very much supply
lead inflation interest rates are not
particularly good at controlling uh
supply-led inflation so
who knows to what extent that will have
an effect
the investment volumes
q1 around 13 billion um industrial
assets quite a big part of that
in retail retail warehousing is the is
probably the sector of choice the
strongest choice there there's still
quite a
um
[Music]
a revolution going on in town centers
and some questions to how that's going
to go forward um
there had been some quite significant
capital value increases but there's a
decline in the rate of capital value
increases
um capital value growth year on year to
january this year was 20.7 and that's
the highest figure since 2010.
um
the rate of growth in rental values has
also declined um but there has been a
modest improvement in the retail and
office sectors as you know the
industrial sector as you probably know
the industrial sector has been um
extremely hot
um looking at trends for 2022
investors tending to focus on new
opportunities um the increase in
distressed assets trading in most
sectors apart from logistics
as i said retail warehousing is the
sector of choice in retail
um
rising rents rents rates sorry and
inflation will tend to intensify the
hunt for yields a lot of investors are
looking for to try to find yield
um and looking at that possibly through
mergers and acquisitions jv's etc as
well and some of the lenders major
lenders are coming back to the market
there's a stronger demand likely in the
hotel and hotel and retail sectors and
certainly the flexible office market is
also one that's coming back as well
looking then just quickly at
the occupy market and i say
retail has had a very interesting time
and i think obviously what happened with
the pandemic really hastened what was
happening anyway in terms of online
sales and
taking that on but there is some sign
that uh consumers are thinking perhaps
there's a little bit on too much online
and you can see there the peak of 36
percent in early 2021 was down to 25 in
january so that's interesting there is
still very definitely a place for the
high street and for um
physical retail um so the footfall has
been improving
um
the retail landscape has changed
fundamentally but there's still um
definitely a need for
physical retail
um there are new businesses coming to
the market with
different uh modus operandi
um
so
of course we have to look as well though
the cost of living crisis the
invasion of ukraine and everything there
is having a significant effect on the
whole economy generally
looking at offices um there's still good
demand for the right stock
the big six office markets are all
recording have been recording higher
take-ups and an increase in rents
um
the second half of 2021 take-up was
quite strong 50 ahead of the first half
and only four percent down on the
same period in 2019
as i mentioned before flexible office
operators are returning to the market
there's been a slight upward trend in
supply of office space except in bristol
lee's and that's mainly from speculative
development so development is is
happening it's
still very much a place for offices in
spite of the working for home
and certainly growth is expected in
prime rents
the very hot market of course has been
sorry do you wish me to should i stop
waiting uh yeah so i'm trying to get
their attention um i just wanted to make
the observation and i think we mentioned
this last time
um i don't know about anyone else but i
can't see what's going on here
and we had this i think we mentioned it
before with the slides they if they're
going to be presented they need to be
readable
there's so much on here it's so tiny are
we able to put it on the screen
was that not possible
i mean i'm assuming he's reading it all
but i can't see what's up there emily
if i could just interject so this data
is all included in the report that you
that you've read so the purpose of the
presentation isn't to provide any new
information it's just to provide some
headlines so chris is covering um
everything that's on those slides we're
more than happy to circulate a copy of
the slides afterwards if that would be
helpful and but all of the data is
within the within the report so there
isn't anything new here we're just
trying to highlight something
i think a councillor barrett mentions a
lot could we just maybe next time make
sure that we can see this otherwise you
might as well switch it off
your comments are noted
yeah thank you very much dawson
thank you i all i mean i just highlight
the main points but as i say i'm trying
not to miss anything out but
um so the industrial warehouse sector
has still has been very powerful um big
take-up in the western corridor um
highest ever figure apart from 2011
available supplies down the uk vacancy
rate is down there's been certainly a
surge in rental values in most areas and
very strong investor and developer
sentiment
hopefully hopefully you can see the
figures here on the slide the um it's
just a quick summary of the portfolio um
from q1 2020 through to 2020 while in
2022 you see the total asset value there
in the first line uh the contracted rent
we've been working hard to improve you
can see that has gone up
um the erv the estimated rental value
has also gone up
um number of assets obviously from 21 to
22
was the same
number of tenants has gone down slightly
just because of negotiation of uh
lettings of other units
um the
walt the unexpired letting term
has gone down slightly that's to
expected we do have a a little bit of a
high eight what a lot of height is but
in 25 26 there are a few more things
coming to the market so we work coming
we're working hard to make sure that
that doesn't cause any um
significant vacancies in the portfolio
um you can see the yields um tended to
come down because of the increasing
value um but the running yield is still
5.36 it's producing a very good return
to
our shareholders
next slide please
here you can see um as i mentioned
before the valuation has gone up by just
over 10 million and here is a detail of
that um i won't go through it in in any
detail you may not be able to see the
figures from from where you are but as
emily says you've been you have been
supplied with them it's always a very
pleasing um
increase in value in the portfolio
next slide please
and really just to
look at the portfolio weighting um it is
a
it's a very secure portfolio of secure
assets you can see on the left there um
the
split between the various sectors it's
uh there's a
weighting in industrial which has been
very good as added value provided very
good income the office sector is the
next biggest
alternative is 11
and then some retail split between high
street retail and retail warehouse
and then looking at the um
the diagram on the right hand side you
can see that the vast majority of the
assets are core long-let liquid assets
some value-added assets
we found in our
out in our acquisition that we we
couldn't find any of the opportunities
opportunistic assets at the right sort
of price and therefore we ended up with
a portfolio which is slightly more
secure
than perhaps we had envisaged at the
beginning we thought we might have a
small proportion in assets where there
was the opportunity to add value but at
the time we were acquiring those were
rather expensive and therefore we
decided not to proceed with those and on
that i will hand over to emily to talk
in detail about the portfolio and the
way forward
thanks chris good morning everyone and
so as chris has mentioned the focus this
year has been on managing the portfolio
and so part of
the management portfolio is ensuring the
quality of the assets that we have
as well as looking at some of the voids
that came forward as part of the
impact of the pandemic
and so we have actually spent
around about 760 000 pounds on the
portfolio this year
on a number of um investments in
properties so the most significant of
which was units two and three pasadena
way in harlow
that property
was vacated during the pandemic when the
tenant unfortunately went into
administration we have undertaken a full
refurbishment to that property
spending just under 500 000 pounds on
the property including um replacing the
roof
and also adding some new solar panels to
the property
that property is actually one that's
seen the greatest increase in value so
having invested around 460 470 000
pounds we've seen an increase in value
of around 60 60 percent
sorry keith
sorry
uh
just make out the point that some of the
information we're seeing on the screen
is actually in the confidential papers
and redacted
and we are in public session
it's like the name of the tenant for
example etc
that's fine the the main issues with the
confidentiality really relate to the
lease term elements so as this is an
investment of um sifco's capital funding
that's fine and in reality the names of
the tenants are public information in
terms of the addresses but but thank you
for checking that's appreciated
thank you
so in terms of the um investment in
harlow that saw an increase in value of
around about 60 about
1.1 million pounds so that's proved to
be a really um prudent investment we've
got a good new tenant in there and who's
very satisfied and we've got a building
that's more robust and more sustainable
for the future
and we've also undertaken probably the
next largest uh investment was uh an
investment in renaissance house uh
upgrading the
the common parts and we invested a
hundred thousand pounds or thereabouts
in that element to try to attract some
further tenants
there were some further smaller
investments made um in the other
property in harlow
a small property in norwich and one in
coventry as well
so if we just move on
and i've got some photographs showing
some of those works and so this is the
property renaissance house in epsom
and this is some of the refurbishment
works that we've undertaken
in terms of the the common parts so
that's things like the reception areas
the halls and stairways
and the wc's and so those works were
completed actually below budget
and we're hoping those will help to
attract more tenants to this building uh
moving forward
and the this is project i've just
mentioned at a pasadena trading estate
in harlow you can see a before and after
photograph there and so as i mentioned
we've seen the value increase
significantly by around 60 percent
and we've also managed to improve the
epc rating of this property as well from
a low c to a high b
and so
a kind of
wins on both a financial perspective but
also from a sustainability perspective
as well
next year or this current financial year
and we're looking at some further
capital investments in the portfolio we
are looking at um
further investment in renaissance house
we have a void there on the first floor
and looking at some options to see
whether we can um
subdivide it further to make it more
attractive to the local market so we've
got a potential budget in there of 125
000 pounds and
along with 45 000 pounds for some
external repairs to renaissance house as
well
we're also looking at the epcs of all of
our properties within the portfolio
and we've put forward a small relatively
small budget of 50 000 pounds to be able
to
fund some of the necessary upgrades as
part of our epc review process
so that could be a number of small
amendments or changes to
more units or it could be
one or two more significant investments
depending on what will help to deliver
the best results
and then in terms of lootier house and
west park house
we're looking at some capital investment
to undertake some survey um
during the the course of this year and
to tie in with the uh approaching
expires in 2026.
so in terms of our uh
key performance indicators um
this table shows uh our performance uh
this year and so the first uh kpi was
looking at increasing the contracted
rent from five million pounds and by cpi
plus one percent and i think in fairness
we probably hadn't envisaged that um
we'd see inflation at the levels that we
we have seen over this last year and but
we're pleased that um despite the the
high levels of inflation we have
actually managed to meet that target um
just admittedly but we have met that
target so we're pleased to have seen
that
um
the equivalent yield we've seen um
a slight reduction against target but as
chris mentioned earlier that's uh due to
the increase in the value of the
portfolio so it's actually a kind of
positive underperformance in some ways
we are suggesting next year that we look
to benchmark
the equivalent yield against other
portfolios rather than having a a target
score
again in terms of the
epc scores we've had a focus this year
as we've mentioned on reducing
our overall
impact on
in terms of sustainability so you can
see we have achieved that by reducing
the overall score
it's quite a complex kpi that we devised
last year and we are suggesting a change
to that which i'll talk about in a
moment which is perhaps more in keeping
with the proposed changes to legislation
and then finally we always keep a very
close eye on our renter ears
because incoming is very important and
you can see consistently that
we have been below that five percent
target um with arrears tending to be by
the end of the um
the quarter close to that one and a
quarter percent so the march figures um
are from about four weeks ago so we're
actually very close to the um
you know one and a half percent that
we've seen
over the last year
in terms of uh kpis for next year um
again
we have tweaked these slightly just to
reflect the change in circumstances that
we have so in terms of our increased
rent
with
what's happening with inflation it
doesn't seem appropriate to link
kpi to inflation so we're looking for a
greater than one percent increase in um
in the contracted rent for for next year
as i mentioned we're looking to
benchmark um the equivalent yield and
so we're looking for it to align with or
be above the old property shield
which is currently 5.3 percent so
obviously if that's 5.4
next year that's what we'll be looking
at
but i think benchmarking is probably a
more appropriate way of
monitoring our performance in that
regard
and with regard to um
the sustainability uh key performance
indicator what we're suggesting is that
we
um seek to align with the proposed
changes to me's and epc legislation
which is that
by 2027 all commercial properties will
have an epc rating of c or above and we
currently have um just under 42 of our
portfolio that are rated c or above i
think that's probably a
more transparent method of monitoring
our performance in that space
and then finally the last kpi
is consistent with the one that we've
had for several years
in regard to the renteries and making
sure they're less than five percent
of the portfolio
so in terms of uh the business plan for
2223
and these are the key um
focuses
so we're looking to retain all of the
assets within the portfolio and there
are no sales currently anticipated we do
review uh each of the assets
on an annual basis but also on a
quarterly basis to see whether um we
should look uh to consider any sales
we're looking to maximize um revenue for
the portfolio and that is largely
through being very proactive with our
tenants
and
with the lease events that we've got
coming up
we're retaining our focus on esg and
looking to enhance the sustainability of
the portfolio holders so sorry the
portfolio
and we have
an action plan that we're looking to
deliver we're looking to be able to
demonstrate and how we've
achieved against that action plan
and we continue to maintain
tight budgetary and credit control over
the company so again
monitoring
our renters very carefully particularly
and
we do that on a
daily and weekly basis
because it has such a big impact
on our
portfolio as a whole
we do need to manage lease expiries and
events
throughout the portfolio
so that we can reduce our void risk we
look at these well in advance
and look to see where we can um
reduce any particular pockets of um
grouped expiries as chris mentioned
earlier we do have some coming up in 25
26 and that we're looking to be very
proactive about
um i've already provided a bit of a
breakdown in terms of our capital
expenditure that we're proposing for for
this year and but we do need to be
strategic about how we use those those
sums
and ultimately we're looking to
implement our individual asset
initiatives
so that we can create more added value
to the portfolio
the
other thing that is really key to us
particularly in a market and that we're
currently seeing is that we
closely monitor
what's happening in the market and we're
very fortunate to have some very good
advisors in that regard
and it's really about looking at the
opportunities that we have so that we
can enhance value and income but also
maintain that liquidity
and then finally it's the kind of longer
term piece in terms of cifco's
resilience as a as a financial model to
be able to deliver income back to
both of the councils
and so again that moves on to
the tables which are in the um
i think both the
report and the business plan uh sections
that have already been published um and
are
the tables that we've used for the last
few years so you can see the cumulative
income and
movements
over the last
four four or five years or so
and so as chris mentioned
earlier
mid-suffolk has benefited from net
income of around about 1.7 million
uh whilst baba received net income of
around about two million pounds and
overall the councils have benefited from
uh about nine and a quarter million
since sifko's inception
in 2017.
so
we have included the draft cifco
accounts within the um within the papers
um and uh
whilst there will be some changes to
these they are only draft accounts but
in previous years they they have been
requested the kind of key headlines from
that are that civco has made pre-tax
profit for around about nine million
pounds and a post-tax profit of around
about six and a half million pounds and
the main reason for the profit is the
increase in value of the portfolio and
that we've seen which was around about
10 million pounds around about 12
in you know
so then finally um just in terms of the
conclusions
so the the business plan um is a really
important framework it's really
important part of civco's governance
ensuring that we manage the portfolio in
an effective um and sensible way
the kpis again provide that framework so
that civco's performance
can be monitored but also so that you
can see the priorities
transparently
from the actions that we take
and the existing portfolio is balanced
it does have um
risk as any portfolio does but that's
diversified
across the sector location
and tenants that we have
and this approach has proved successful
during the pandemic
where we've been able to continue to
mitigate civco's risk and the risk to
its shareholders
civco continues to provide the capitals
with an important income stream
and over the longer term further capital
growth is expected as well
the
i suppose the final point just to raise
in terms of the
report this year is we are proposing a
change to the governance
um
to really reflect that we're in the
business as usual stage of pacifico
rather than the acquisition stages that
we had previously
and so we're proposing that um
the
business plan is approved by the holding
companies scrutinized by ons and if ons
think it's necessary it can then be
referred onto full council rather than
it automatically being referred on to
full council and part of the reason for
that i think is to ensure that we have a
transparent and single conversation and
we've had some really beneficial debates
about sifko over the last few years and
but i'm conscious we hold it in three
different places and it might actually
be more transparent if we have a single
place to have that that debate and
that's what we're we're proposing this
year
um so that
is the end of our presentation but we'd
be more than happy to to take any
questions thank you
thank you very much uh to both of you
for the presentation
um yes open to questions who um
councillor grandin and then councillor
muller please
thank you chair
thank you there were really good
presentations and
the question i have to ask you have
touched upon both of you in
in your presentation but i just would
like it
clarified please
um
obviously it's been a long time now
since um the inception of cifco
and since the purchase of the properties
and since then we all know that there
have been a lot of changes
in
the country in the world
i'm
a little concerned about the balance
now
of the portfolio because while it might
have seemed
right
at the inception of the organization
is
can you reassure me that that or us
sorry that that balance is still
accurate going forward
because
retail i was always a little concerned
about
office
of course at the time that um
you
those
um
that portfolio the office portfolio was
added
um
seemed the obvious and correct thing but
we all know now that work from home
is becoming a bigger and bigger thing so
going forward
um
with
organizations reducing their
the number of people going into the
office
how will that affect
our our portfolio and the balance that
we hold um
i'm a little concerned now whether it
still holds in the change marketplace
thank you
yeah thank you very much um i mean i i
think it's important to say obviously as
we started in 2017 you're quite right
and we set things out then as to what we
were intending to do but in fact even
through the acquisition phase we did
change our our focus and we ended up
with probably less retail than we had
originally envisaged um certainly more
industrial than we had in literature so
throughout the acquisition process we
were we were changing things having then
completed that um obviously we are now
we we now have our portfolio and
in the longer term we will be looking at
some assets we may decide that we don't
wish to retain but also and we you know
we may wish to sell and and reinvested
into different assets um but also we're
looking at continually improving the um
the quality of the assets and emily was
talking in detail about what we've done
at pacific in a way and the effect that
that had in value so that's something
that the board is is looking at all the
time in terms of um the sectors you're
absolutely right i mean the retail
sector of course has gone through a very
um difficult phase which is why we we
ended up with a smaller part of our
portfolio in retail than we might have
done
as i said earlier there is still very
much a place for physical retail and it
does appear that the sort of
the amount of online shopping is coming
down at the moment to increase footfall
um
and the office sector there is still
it's quite clear that there is still a
good strong demand for for the office
sector and i mean we have
neville here from jones lang and perhaps
you might never would you like really
just to comment on the various sectors
of the market
now i've mastered the switch i can um
yes
hello everyone
everybody i think we start at the high
level the first thing to say is that the
portfolio was bought as a low-risk
portfolio so rather than buying lots of
things with five minutes on the lease
and having to take a bit of a view as to
what was happening in the occupational
markets then the average unexpired term
on the leases in the portfolio is over
80 years so that is tenants signed up
with a contractual pledge to pay rent
for the next eight years
so
whatever happens in the short term we
have a degree of
medium-term
cover as is the first point at the
higher level
looking at each of the sectors then
the sifko board were
good enough to as chris says
adjust the view
in line with the way the market was
going in the initial investment strategy
so we've got close to half of the
portfolio in industrial and warehouse
properties now that's performed very
well over the last couple of years the
rate of increase in value is
slipping but it is still performing
better than most other sectors and
there's still across the whole country
uh about one and a half percent
see in industrial warehouse property of
current supply
and so as a supply demand balance there
is still a very good
tenant demand and rents are still
increasing so the portfolio is set fair
in terms of a large exposure to that
sector in particular
looking at the other sectors then
retail actually the retail components of
the portfolio went up in value last year
now we all know that there are major
structural changes still ongoing in the
high street
retail warehousing was the comeback kid
last year values in retail warehousing
have improved significantly
and
because
the size of the portfolio precludes
youth moaning very large retail parks um
you've not gained the full balance of
that but the retail warehousing which is
in there has performed well
and so that is also
you know done quite well overall offices
is about a third of the portfolio
and
certainly i think
none of us
expected the impact that kovit has had
and
now
we're at the other side hopefully then
we are seeing people going back to the
office and
working from home
has certain benefits and
i think
we are probably going to see hybrid
working going forwards where most people
are doing three four days a week in the
office
but they still want to be in the office
three four days a week and
all of the conference calls with
children dogs in the background and
you're checking what you think what's
sitting behind you as you're doing the
call everything it is so nice to be back
in the office
at the moment that i think there is
still
um a very good demand for offices and
the letting mark in offices actually is
back to 2019 levels
um
so i don't think we can be
completely gung-ho about it offices have
changed to a degree and i think from our
perspective the
the
one thing we need to do looking forward
is be particularly aware of lease
expires which are coming towards us
and try to negotiate with the tenants to
see what is possible
and ideally extend the leases
maybe it means
giving them a repurposed reception or
something with stairwells or something
of that kind but you can create the
value out of adjusting the lease that
way and so
this is all part of ongoing management
and
if we can keep tenants happy we keep
income coming in
and good management means happy tenants
and maintaining the value and
maintaining the income stream from these
properties and so
if the properties are fundamentally
right in terms of location and
specification at the outset
and you
refurbish as necessary to make sure that
they are still
the
dominant buildings in the local market
then you can maintain that income stream
and that's all part of management going
forwards it's stock selection of the
outset but management going forwards and
that's something which the board are
very focused on
at this stage so
overall i think we're still very happy
with the
portfolio mix as a sector
it is
a balanced portfolio so as one sector
doesn't do as well there is still
something in other sectors which may do
better and so
it will continually be a balance which
moves from one sector to another but
over the years hopefully that
initial strategy of getting a
variety of assets
should hold good it's it's eggs and
baskets fundamentally
um
yes councillor mother
thank you very much for the presentation
that was excellent
it's pleasing to see that the amount of
outstanding arrears is around two
percent but can you please advise me
what action you are taking to ensure
that those areas are actually cleared in
the near future thank you
thank you and so we have um jones lang
lasalle is our portfolio managers but we
also have workmen as our day-to-day
managing agents and workmen are very
effective
at managing our arrears for us we have
fortnightly calls going through all of
the arrears now during the pandemic
we've had limited options available to
us and because of the government kind of
bar on chasing arrears so we haven't
actually been able to undertake any
direct action to recover those areas so
if you look at arrears levels based on
no um
follow-up action you actually can see
that we've been pretty successful and
particularly compared to other um
other similar portfolios within the
market
so we use all of the uh necessary
actions that that we need to the the
first one i think is tenant engagement
so we've got some really good
relationships with tenants and
work from our managing agents we'll
phone them up almost daily to encourage
them to make payments and that has been
probably the most effective method uh to
date with some of the more
challenging areas we have had to take
other actions so car action and
bailiffs if necessary but in reality
we've only done that a very small number
of times the majority of times it's been
about good relationships with tenants
agreeing payment plans if need be
and
actively reminding tenants of their
obligations to to pay us
we do see some bad debts occurring
um
i think we've got around about thirteen
thousand pounds worth of bad debts uh
this year um or this year that's just
gone so you know that's an a normal part
of of property management but i think
we're actually very proactive in terms
of minimizing the the rental areas that
we we've had certainly over the pandemic
i think our rental areas have been
exceptionally low compared to others
thank you
thank you
are there any other
council scarf
and then councillor carter
thank you chair um
well
i'm looking at the key performance
indicators which is one of the things
that we need to look at uh as a scrutiny
committee
um
and we've obviously
going forward for 22 23
we're looking at the equivalent yield of
5.3
i think i understand why that is is
because the value of the portfolio has
increased and therefore the equivalent
yield is going to be less
but we're benchmarking against
no i can't remember what the what the
phrase was um is this is this realistic
or is this
changing the uh key performance
indicator target
more to mirror what's going on in the
wider commercial world
is it is it a smart key performance
indicator
and so it is about changing the key
performance indicators so it reflects
what's happening in the marketplace and
so this is probably a better evidenced
benchmark i would say rather than one
that was um originally set as a an idea
of the type of yield we'd be looking to
um looking to to make so the old
property yield um is a a
benchmark that's used across um the
industry
and will reflect the current market
conditions and if we set a sort of
arbitrary yield that doesn't reflect
market conditions i don't think it does
that accurately demonstrate whether
we're managing the portfolio well or not
because there are certain things that
are outside of our control i think if we
benchmark against what others are doing
in the sector it shows whether we're
doing better or worse than that
benchmark so i actually think it's a
truer and better um
smarter if you'd like uh indicator of um
how civco is actually performing
yes councillor scarf
yes thank you for that yeah that is
quite what i expected
the next area i think i would like to
focus a question on uh is the epc rating
challenge that cifco has which to me
seems to be one of the bigger challenges
that you're going to have to overcome
in the coming years and not too far
ahead either
we've got something like 57 of our
properties in uh epcd and e i understand
you mentioned earlier in the slides a
current action plan
um in terms of the epc
i don't think i've seen it in the papers
because
what what we were what i was interested
in is how are you going to achieve those
epc ratings of c or above in what is
relatively a short timetable bearing in
mind that
you don't have full control over what
happens to the building so perhaps you
can give us some more information on
that and also where could we find the
current action plan in terms of
achieving those epc ratings thank you
thank you so there is a table within the
report and if you bear with me once i've
answered it i'll point you to the um to
the table so that you can have a look at
it
so there are a number of um
actions that we're looking to um bring
forward so as i mentioned in the budget
we've put a 50 000 pound budget in um in
relation to uh sustainability and epcs
so what we're looking to do is renew all
of our epcs that are coming up to expiry
and currently you don't actually have to
do that until you're re-letting a
property
but we're doing that as they come up to
expiry and that's so we can look at what
actions need to be taken
now in a number of cases they're
actually quite small actions that can be
taken that can have actually a really
big impact so we've already seen in some
situations
that
things like having thermostatic controls
on on radiators particularly in some of
the smaller industrial units they don't
have thermostatic controls so making
some very small adjustments um can
actually have quite a big impact on um
on the epc rating
and reduce the um impact on on the
environment
and
as we said um a lot of our properties if
not all of them or very close to all of
them are on pool repairing and ensuring
leases so the responsibility sits with
the tenant
really but as a
um
[Music]
responsible landlord
we're very happy to have conversations
with our tenants to say we've had this
epc um
report it's suggesting these kinds of
measures and having a conversation with
the tenant to see whether there's an
equitable split in terms of um the
investments that we as landlords make
and those that the tenants will look to
make as well so we've got a few
conversations that are ongoing currently
about thermostatic radio uh radiator
controls and
insulating doors better etc
and we've also got some conversations
going on with some of our other tenants
where they're actually looking to
refurbish the premises themselves
and so part of what we've been doing is
saying that's really interesting have
you also thought about how you can
improve the sustainability of your
properties as well whilst you're
undertaking the refurbishments and so
again it's having those conversations to
kind of prompt the thinking um with
those tenants so we've got one fairly
large um
project that we're currently looking at
to see how how we could do that in a
partnership way
and one of the other um things that
we've got within our action plan is
green leases
so what we're trying to do is upgrade
our or update our leases as they come
through again we can't um
we can't do that to all of our
properties we do have to wait for the
leases to come up for
uh renewal and but we're inserting in
some new green clause leases which again
require the tenant not to reduce
the sustainability of their property not
to reduce the epc and to share
information with us because a lot of
um
a lot of the key parts managing a
portfolio in a sustainable way is
actually having some of the data so that
we can see how these properties are
performing and so that's that's quite a
key element and we've had some workshops
with our lawyers and with jll to see how
we can best introduce these new um
green leases and green clauses into into
our leases and and then the other
element is looking at some of the
properties where we have a bit more
control and that that's where we perhaps
manage the properties and we have a
service charge
and so it might be that we're actually
um you know we have an electricity
supply you know we're looking at um
replacing lights in common and common
parts so that we've got more energy
efficient lighting
and so there's a whole
um array of different opportunities that
that we've got um or it might even be
including more bicycle storage et cetera
so there's quite a lot of things we can
do where we've got buildings or estates
that we've got an estate charge or
service charge that we're managing so um
it will be a kind of
incremental
action i suppose with a number of
probably smaller elements all helping us
to achieve and that
2027 um
target and you know once we've achieved
that i think we'll keep going and we'll
actually start to you know to to do the
next step and to reduce the um
the overall rate from a c to you know
maybe an a or a b in due course as well
so it's a continual
piece of work that we're doing with
multiple kind of approaches
and something that we're we as a board
are very committed to i think neville
so i could also just add that epc
assessments actually last for 10 years
and some of the assessments are actually
nearly 10 years old on some of these
buildings
and as well as the proactive
things which sifka are bringing forward
then
in many cases tenants have you know
either because they have a great belief
in the sg or simply because they're
aware of the costs of energy and they're
doing their best to save energy going
forwards and their costs um a number of
them actually taking steps anyway such
that the historic assessments would now
be assessed differently if they were
assessed more recently and so
it's a snapshot and many of these
snapshots are actually quite old now as
well
okay councillor barrow then
um
thank you um councillor carter um i
wanted
on the same sort of theme
i'm continuing on the sort of the epc
and the energy and all those sort of
issues um costs are clearly
crucial to to the success of this aren't
they because otherwise it all disappears
in um
in in your costs or the profit
um and you you're working
with so many different councils across
the
the area the the places where these
investments are
um are you
are you able to fully exploit any grants
any government schemes any
any additional funding for those
those energy saving measures
thank you so um again within the
business plan we do
mention that we will look to achieve um
any external funding we can to help um
the sustainability of
this portfolio so absolutely if there
are opportunities for us to
obtain external funding then we'd be
delighted to pursue those um and
we'll continue to do that and
you know
not only external funding but we also
look at some opportunities that will
help to generate a return as well so the
investment in solar panels in um in
harlow does provide a small return on
the capital invested as well so we'll
look to utilize whatever
financial means that that we have
available to us to be able to help
improve the sustainability of the
portfolio there is obviously a kind of
careful balance because cifico's
main kind of purpose is to get as much
money back to the councils as possible
so that can be invested locally so it's
a careful balance but certainly if we
can achieve external funding and grants
then that's one that's an aspect we are
keen to
pursue thank you
thank you is our follow-up question
councillor
casa carter
thank you sorry about that
um
i am quite excited by the next steps in
the epc and going ahead and always for
being more proactive and being forward
thinking
um
guards be sustainability of
uh
well of cifco um
i assume we also have a mind into us the
same sustainability of our tenants
uh regards their business practices for
people who we have as who we are
landed too
and i'm not just talking about their
business practices of
road usage
business practices of what companies but
we have as our tenants
but also their business practice has the
staff treatments and turnover what
as
shareholders
how does it reflect on us if we have
say warehouses and having some
experience with warehouses i'm pretty
aware of some of the poor treatment we
can have there these staff turn over
for people who are maybe employed
we have as
landlords
we have responsibility for welfare of
our tenants
which we're
as tenants we're looking at
the welfare of the companies or the
welfare of those employed by those
companies and should it's
should there be any fallout from any
poor practices or any fallout from the
companies that we are currently
investing and profiting from
well how does it reflect upon us
thank you councillor carter so
um we obviously as landlords don't um
have any control over how our tenants
run their businesses
on a day-to-day basis we do however
have some responsibility in terms of how
they use our properties and so we do
have regular property inspections and i
think if there are any safeguarding
issues that were identified during those
processes then our managing agents who
undertake those inspections would would
flag those
and certainly from a health and safety
from the building perspective and i know
things like making sure fire escapes etc
are kept clear again is something that
is um
very key to
the property manager's inspection so
just looking at the overall safety of
the building
is something that our
managing agents will do with their
regular inspections and again i'm sure
they would flag any safeguarding issues
as well um but ultimately our tenants
have the right to um
[Music]
quiet enjoyment of their spaces so we
can't interfere in the running of their
businesses having said that we do seek
to um have good quality tenants in our
in our spaces um and so
whilst we can't control their activities
assuming they do remain legal obviously
um
we do um to date i don't think we've had
any um safeguarding items flagged with
us certainly from a property
safeguarding spaces any issues that have
been flagged have then been followed up
and so that those issues have been been
resolved so we continue to be a
responsible landlord as far as our kind
of jurisdiction as a landlord exists
thank you
thank you do you have another question
no thank you uh councillor caston
sorry i don't seem to have a microphone
oh yeah i know it's on there yeah
um yeah i don't want to get too hung up
on the epc because
the um
c or above by 2027 is quite a clear
message of where we're going with it but
we do at this stage we do start to look
a lot more at the maintenance and the
improvement
of the assets
but um
my question was um
do we have information on the heat and
light requirement of our tenants when we
um when we're looking into epc
improvements um
the there's obviously different ways of
going about it you've got the low
hanging fruit way where you you do the
things that gets the biggest return on
your money
for epc reduction but also on the other
side there's lots of different uses
of these buildings that might require
a different um might require
more of a priority for instance like a
waiting room
will need to be kept to a higher
temperature than a warehouse um is this
something that we're looking at
when we're looking at these epc
improvements
thank you so that's all part of the epc
inspection so the
qualified inspectors who go out to
undertake the
epc assessments will look at
the properties and
how they're being used you might find in
a parade of
six industrial units that they'll all
have different ratings
and that's often down to how the tenants
are occupying and using and using their
spaces so what we
then look to in terms of
determining which works should be
prioritized is really the advice that
comes back from um the epc assessors
they make some recommendations in terms
of um
the things that they think will make the
biggest difference to those those
individual properties and what cifco
needs to do is then look across all of
that data
and we have it in in batches because
we'll have
maybe 10 epc
reassessed at any particular time we'll
look at it in in batches across that
data and to see what's going to deliver
the best returns but also in terms of
talking to our tenants it's also about
what we can agree with our tenants so we
may have some works that might
um improve the sustainability of that
property more than other works but
actually they're not deliverable from
the tenants operational perspective so
we have to find that balance between
what we can deliver working with the
tenants
and and the kind of
outputs of that
sustainability work
thank you uh councillor grandin
and are there any other speakers after
councillor grandin
i've got some questions i'll be looking
for any further questions after that so
councillor grandin please
thank you chairman
um
the presentation included a couple of
references to
the term added value
um and i presume that refers to added
value to the tenants
um
[Music]
i i presume you're
um first
um criteria is to
return money to the councils in in
profit
how do you
kind of balance that
apart from maintenance and i understand
you have to keep your
your tenants happy
but
it isn't added value
um
giving them something for nothing
effectively
[Music]
i understand maintenance has to be done
but that's a different thing to added
value
so
i'm a bit concerned you might be giving
them too much and up to the
[Music]
detriment of profits that might be
returned to the council could you
explain that please
yes certainly thank you so i think when
we're talking about added value we're
actually talking about the value that we
add to the portfolio so we're not
talking about added value to our tenants
and customers it's actually about adding
value to the portfolio but i think your
question is is a really good one in
terms of how do we balance
um the needs of our shareholders
with running the company and um and our
and our tenants so as directors we have
a responsibility to ensure that the
company is well run um and that we act
in the best interests of of the company
so that's a kind of a key element of how
we assess everything that we're doing
and
we do want to get money back to the the
councils that was the reason cifco was
set up
and but in order to do that in a
sustainable way we need to make sure
that the company is resilient and robust
as well so we do have to look at
balancing what cifco needs in order to
operate for the longer term as well as
the amount of income that comes back to
the shareholders and equally what we're
able to invest in it in our in our
tenants um i don't know whether chris
wants to add anything further to that
yeah i was just going to say i mean i
think um it is a very good question um
but if you look at what emily was
talking about with pasadena the the work
we did there you know that capital
expenditure there are 460 000 now that's
obviously something which the board
looked at pretty hard and thought now
this is a significant amount of money
but you know if you look at it you spend
460 000 but it's increased the value of
the asset by 1.125 million so those are
the sort of things that we're looking at
and i absolutely agree with emily that
when we're looking at added value we're
talking about the value of the portfolio
thinking about as far as shareholders
are concerned um so
that's the important thing but obviously
working with the tenants and making it's
about making the um the assets we have
as attractive as possible to those
tenants either the existing tenants or
if we've got a vacant unit new tenants
coming in so it it it's all about
balance um but it when we're talking
about um
added value this is very much the
portfolio rather more than the tenants
themselves
thank you for clearing up my
misunderstanding
thank you um
if there's no other questions at the
minute can i
they're fairly straightforward fairly
quick questions or the answers should be
quite short i haven't on page 15 you
talk about the kpis for
uh 2223
kpi1
the target
was for the last year cpi
plus one percent which worked out at
7.27 in the end which was um good
so why should we think that
um a target anything greater than one
percent should be a good target for
uh for the next year
um
and
the other the other was on a target
three
if you know that currently 41.8 percent
of the portfolio
are rated c or above why don't we have
any intermediate targets why have we
only got the target to be met at 2027
why don't we for instance say
with a certain percentage by
the end of the current year
thank you so um
we hadn't expected um cpi to be um
six percent uh when we set the targets
last year and actually we'd anticipated
that we probably wouldn't make that
target as we saw inflation growing so we
were really pleased to see that we
actually had
and if you look at what's happened over
the the last 12 months with the
portfolio we have actually reduced the
voids quite considerably so at the end
of last year
we had a more vacant property because of
the impacts of the pandemic and so there
was more opportunity really to grow our
rental base because of that
and
from this year we're actually looking at
very low void rates of just under two
percent
um so in reality we have less
opportunity to increase the rental value
of the properties of the portfolio as a
whole this year because we don't have as
much void uh property so i think in
previous years chris has talked about
how sometimes the having voids is also
an opportunity as well as a threat when
looking at cifco so moving forward this
year with the uncertainty of the
economic conditions the fact that we've
got low void rates
we don't think it's realistic to set a
target that
exceeds the one that we've put there so
we put one percent as a
a minimum
target you also have to factor in with
those lower void rates we've got
contractual terms already in place with
tenants so we don't have a situation
where we can just say to tenants so
we're now putting your rent up by three
percent it's based on what's in the the
lease already so assessing the lease
events that we've got coming forward we
think that um
you know in excess of one percent is a
reasonable target for this year again
we'll review that next year if we uh by
looking at what opportunities there are
in the following year looking at our
performance this year and you know it
may be appropriate to increase that
target next year but the board felt that
that was an appropriate the board and
our advisors actually thought that was
an appropriate target to have for for
this year bearing in mind the where we
are with the portfolio and where we off
the market thank you
and the other was the intermediate
targets on the epc rating yeah and
that's an interesting one that we
thought about quite hard so last year
when we introduced the um kpi for
sustainability we were sort of trialling
um how to best do that and what we found
was it was a little bit clunky and but
we also found that it takes some time to
actually
implement the
um
the new sustainable features so
depending on when the um
epcs are renewed when the work's done
when they're then reclassified that can
take some time so again as a board we
thought that having a a longer-term kpi
which we will monitor progress against
um annually would be
more um more effective than having um a
shorter kpi because again it's about
making the right decisions
not the decision that's just going to
meet the kpi and it felt that having
that slightly longer term kpi was
probably the right thing to do for the
portfolio thank you but you would be
able this time next year you would be
able to report progress
on that target towards the 2027 target
yes that's the intention so um within
the kpi we put the percentage that we
are currently at so we'd look to update
that percentage next year so that we can
show um
the move from just under 50 hopefully to
above that figure so we can see the kind
of incremental improvements in reality
it's not that long a kpi so unless we
make some improvements this year it's
going to be quite difficult for us to
achieve longer term so yes we'll we'll
share that data in
a year's time
thank you i've got a question on
it's the tables on pages 17 and
18.
um
the line
are under revenue impact interest paid
it goes up and then it's starting to
drop off again this is on the baby
and
the numbers on the mid suffolk page
are quite different why why are they
uh the interest paid so different on for
the two different districts please
thank you so i might refer to
military as our 151 officer right but in
effect both paper and mid suffolk have
different borrowing strategies so their
interest costs are different um and so
that's why the interest paid figure is a
different figure because that's the cost
to the council of the um the debt that
they've borrowed so the figures received
from cifco at a gross level are the same
for both councils but the costs of the
council's debt is different
and that's the um that's the difference
between those figures unless melissa
wants to correct me
so they are vastly different by the
looks of it the figures are vastly
different so the
the way that
the different two districts have
borrowed the money is
totally different thank you
um there was one other question i had um
and emily this was a statement that you
made
the last two of us but one
slide which is
it is said that there is a
pre-tax profit of 6.5 million
made up it's mainly due to the increase
in value of 10 million now if i took
that can't tell the full story because
if i took six 6.5 million away from 10
million
i would come to the conclusion that
apart from the increase in the value he
made a loss of 3.5 million over the year
how'd that come
no so the pre-tax profit was actually
9.1 million and the post tax sorry post
tax profit yeah
6.5 million so there's some deferred tax
and that that's due and so between those
two figures and so the increase in the
value of the portfolio was around about
just under 10 million and so that's
really where you're seeing that and
pre-tax profit coming through from so
it's a as a consequence of the increase
in capital value of the portfolio
so without
without the increase in the value of the
portfolio there would have been a loss
and there's a small operating loss
within the um the draft accounts and and
that's because of
uh cifco making full debt repayments to
the council so he gets all of that
income back to the council rather than
it being retained in in cifco so yes a
small
operating loss within and within civco
this year which we had anticipated and
but yes the increase in the value of the
property much like last year we had
pre-tax losses as a consequence of the
value of the portfolio going down this
year we're seeing pre-tax profit because
of the value of the
assets going up
again we've got helen uh from nsors if
if there are any more detailed um
questions in relation to the accounts
these are the draft accounts and there
will be some further adjustments um to
be made before they become the final and
final accounts
yeah i haven't got any
sort of deeper questioning on that topic
but thank you very much for those
answers counselor casting
thank you very much um
are we able going forward to um
reinvest
increase the size of this portfolio
in the net i'm not talking about now but
over
over the next sort of five ten years
using the um
profits or the the rent income are we
allowed to do that and would that be
possible if
we um we decided that was a direction we
wanted to go down
and so the
profits from cifco can be reinvested in
in cifco activity and with the agreement
of
the shareholder
so ultimately it will be a kind of
councillors decision
we do need to
make our debt repayments and that's how
the um
that's how the councils
make their kind of net
income from cifco is through repayment
of debt
within the business plan you'll see that
again we've retained the ability and to
defer payments for the next couple of
years um so that there is the ability to
to slightly reduce those payments as was
agreed uh by full councils last year
but in the future we could look at civco
retaining more
more of its income so that it can be
invested to increase the the value of
the portfolio longer term that could be
an option and for future uh business
plans
yeah so yes carry on is the room in
anyone's mind an appropriate time when
that would take place you know because
obviously we're in very early days of
this
investment portfolio is there a um
is there a good time or
no i mean a part of our role of the
board is to monitor the portfolio as it
goes forward looking to see what's
happening in the market working with
jones lang
so it you know it's difficult to say now
that we think this is one that we might
want to sell or we might want to
reinvest so this is a good sector to
invest in it's it's something that since
we started in 2017 as i said even while
we were going to the acquisition phase
we were slightly changing our focus um
and we will be monitoring the portfolio
going forward to make sure that all of
our assets are
working well and often when you when you
look at an asset you it would have a
sort of a value curve you know you do a
new lease or whatever puts its value
right up and it may then the actual
value may go down so there may be times
when we think actually this is an asset
that perhaps we should sell we can then
reinvest in something where there's more
opportunity you know which is a lower
point in the value curve and therefore
there's more opportunity to add value so
that's something that the board will be
doing all the time working with our
advisors as we go forward and it's
difficult to say here and now there is a
right time to do it because it you know
it depends on the market we see what's
happened over the last year or two and
then with the pandemic and obviously
with ukraine and things like that having
an enormous effect on the market so to
an extent we can overreact those things
and we can also look forward and think
right what is likely to happen in the
market as well
if if there are no further questions
then we will move to debate
and council humphreys
thank you mr chair um
well in these wild and turbulent times
that caused by world events where all
businesses are affected and as well as
individuals it's really refreshing to
see such a good report in fact
somebody's doing well so good for you
and uh and it's down to the experts in
front of us we're not the experts these
guys are we trust you to make the right
investments the harlow investment was
particularly
canny
and see that return is incredible so all
i've said is well done um i wish i had
your crystal ball for my share
investments because they're not as good
as my wife will tell you all of my
money's been sunk but i'm sure they'll
come back up again so um i might be
calling on you for some advice in the
future but well done good report and
it's really really really nice to see my
only because you've always got a down
bit my only point is on page 20 where
you've got risk assessment chart that'd
be really useful for the future if you'd
use a rag system where you can put it in
colour so if it is bad put it in red so
we can see it because to be honest your
2 3 and 6 means nothing to me so and i
don't think it means very much to
anybody else unless you've seen the
matrix so you put the matrix in we'll
change the colours and that's it's a
really minor point so well done and
thank you for this report
thank you um
anyone next
uh if there's no
if there is no debate we need to look at
the
recommendations or the
the recommendations that we
would pass on to
cabinet and council council i think in
this case
um
so uh councillor scarf
yeah um
one in particular chair um the
recommendation 3.3 which we have
discussed actually in terms of the
governance model um
that the business plans are scrutinized
by the council's joint overview and
scrutiny committee and only reported to
council if the committee is not
satisfied with the company's business
plan and performance um
i'm not overly happy i can see the
reasoning why they're recommending the
change in the governance model there but
i'm not overly happy because
cifco i think
is an issue wider than just
the 12 members of the joint overview and
scrutiny committee and always
since i've been on this council has
created a lot of interest
sometimes controversy etc
and i'm wondering if if we make this
recommendation whether we're going to
further down the line find the members
who are not on overbearing scrutiny
committee you're going to go well we
haven't got and we haven't got the
opportunity to look at cifco and and
debate it if this goes forward so i i
wouldn't be happy with recommendation
3.3 i think it's of such importance the
value of this portfolio because of the
income that we receive from this
portfolio that it actually does go to
council even if it's
a half an hour at council or whatever
but it's i think it's for council um
to decide whether they wish to go into
it
so i i wouldn't support recommendation
3.3
just to clarify that is going to be a
council decision you'll only be
recommending to council if you agree
with that it is a fine because council
can only deal with governance
arrangements so you you'll only
recommend to council if that is the way
you want to you know to go forward but
it's ultimately for council to decide
[Music]
yeah i think that has clarified the
situation that we
yeah we we're not making the decision on
whether or not business plans
are scrutinized only by overview and
scrutiny but
the converse of what's
in 3.3 would be that we recommend
we've got an opportunity here to either
recommend that
overview and scrutiny
look at look at the
business plan
and only report on
if we've got concerns about it
the alternative is that we recommend
that
it well exactly as as is here am i right
but we have the opportunity today to
recommend recommending
one way or the other but but yeah we're
not making the
decision to also clarify ultimately it's
always council who agrees the business
plan for cifco as well
well that's
you can scrutinize it but at the end of
the day it's um council that has the
decision making powers you you don't
unfortunately
well
i i don't think that's unfortunately
that i think i think that the re my
reading of 3.3 is
that it would only be reported to
council if the committee is not
satisfied
so
yeah emily
thank you
so currently the business plan is um
prepared and written and approved by the
board of scifico
and it is then um
referred to the
both both councils holding companies for
approval it then comes through to ons
and then full council what is being
proposed um is that the civco board will
approve the business plan holding
companies will approve the business plan
and it will come forward to ons for
scrutiny if ons are not happy with it
for any reason then you could either
refer it back to the holding companies
and then go back through that cycle or
just refer it straight up to full
council so it's just to um shorten the
governance route um in reality you know
we're already in june this will go to
full council in july uh
finance
financial year starts on the 1st of
april we're now in the management stage
of this um
of this fund rather than the acquisitive
phase that we were
earlier and so just slightly shortening
the governance
cycle seemed like a reasonable
suggestion but as the governance
officers have suggested it's a decision
for full council ultimately about
whether they want to retain
um
the right to approve the business plan
or or not but it would be helpful to
have your views on on whether that's
something you would support or not
counselor scarf well in that case chair
i mean thank you for the explanation but
i think we should perhaps then recommend
as a scrutiny committee that it does go
to council
for for i think it's just such an
important issue
um that it ought to
thank you um
does anybody have the same view as
councillor scarf
councillor hinton and then councillor
grandin please
uh yes mr chairman i agree with cancer
scar one of the things that uh
if we're not careful we're going to sort
of gloss over
is as
mr hart has said that
properties
can increase in value and sometimes it
pays to dispose of them when they get to
a high value in order to reinvest in
other properties from a lower value to
keep the the whole process evolving if
you like so i think it's important that
full council is kept fully and fully up
to date with those sorts of proceedings
and i think for us to then say
if we don't disagree with it then that's
it
um
rather devalues the whole purpose of
having a council in first place
thank you casa grandin
i agree with the previous comments so i
think it's such an important part of
or has become such an important part of
the council business
that
i
and
historically has been controversial
i think it would be
wrong for it not to for council and not
to have an opportunity to discuss and
debate
thank you
thank you
uh um we just hear from um the deputy
monitoring officer first and then
council barra um what i would just say
is if you're going to council and
council is going to have a full if you
decide that's what you want to recommend
to council and council's going to have a
full debate on the business plan i think
you need to ask your question what added
value then does overview and scrutiny
add to you know if it's going to full
council for full debate what we're
trying to do is is see what the added
value is
from yourselves and if
you know are we duplicating if you're
already going to have that debate at
council does it then need to come to
overview and scrutiny so perhaps the
question is to turn around does it need
to come to overview and scrutiny or
should it just go to council for review
and that's just the question i'm
throwing out there
thank you uh councillor barrett and
they'll come back to cancer
there is this confusion isn't there um
because i thought we were we were making
some recommendations to full council on
this so that the final debate can take
place there
so i
um but uh yeah i agree what um perhaps
it should have just gone to full council
but i think it does have to go to full
council
so yeah as it stands at the moment it
does have to go to full council so
um you know
it's such
you've got two processes it comes to
overview and scrutiny you make
recommendations to council but you could
in effect shortcut that by going
straight to council so um you know
that's what councils need to consider
here i'm not giving any any types of
views
you could do as emily has suggested and
just let the holding company um agree
the business plan with you reviewing it
that would work alternatively do you
need to review it or if you want it to
go to council for the debate then should
it just go to full council and that's a
question that i'm throwing out to you
councillor casten
thank you very much yeah i've i came to
this meeting thinking it probably
shouldn't go to full council
but
representations here have made me and
think
well
it does it does need to it does need to
be looked at but what um jan is
suggesting there
that it doesn't go through scrutiny and
go straight to full council i think to
be honest that is probably not
a bad direction to moving it's um we
have got to be careful there's a holding
company that um looks after itself we
have got to make sure we add value to
things when they go through and
it's um
and we we shouldn't be having meetings
for the sake of it so my um thoughts
would be
if it must go to full council
send it straight to um full council
i mean if yeah members believe it must
go to the front countries these members
believe it doesn't have to the holding
company can agree it but it's a change
of governance arrangements which council
would have to agree
but you could recommend it just you know
just for clarity but i'm i'm saying does
it need to go to to overview and
scrutiny and council if if that's the
route you're considering because there
is a duplication as we go forward
there's going to be
less and less of value that these
committees can add to this
which um which does make me think there
will be a time
um when it doesn't need to go to it
could just be a scrutiny subject looked
at the committee here is perfectly
capable of looking at reports what we do
every single meeting and um and picking
things out of it but
from what i'm hearing here is it's
really important because
it's a large fund and everything that it
goes to full council so
i believe really that it should just go
to full council and not through the
scrutiny committee just to um
just to streamline things and um
and
just to um reduce the danger of doing
the same
thing twice the same tasks twice
thank you councillor grandin
thank you chairman
we spent about an hour and 40 minutes
also
on this matter here
and that is the advantage of overview
and scrutiny
we are able to look at it in detail
and it's such an important matter that
it requires this time and detail
in a full council meeting
you would not be
uh
i would hope we would not be giving an
hour and 40 minutes to one item as
important as it is
because i would have hoped that overview
and scrutiny would have done the detail
at a previous meeting as we are now
and that the
full council meeting looks at the
overall
um
that the law
other aspects and not as great a detail
as we have the luxury of doing here so i
think we've got slightly two different
purposes
and that
while i
understand it's taking up
sifko's
time
to do this number of presentations and
while it would be nice to
reduce that from their point of view i
think from a governance point of view or
in my opinion
we've got two different
purposes or slightly two different
purposes in in
the amount of detail
each
type of meeting is able to to give to
the matter
yeah thank you um
i've come to you in a minute
what i was going to say was i think i
think that because
we have the time to do this and to
forensically look at it and we can be
pretty certain that we have all read
all the papers very carefully you cannot
be quite so certain that every single
member of council will have will have
had the time to read
all of the papers that we have in front
of us now as well as all of the rest of
the council agenda paper so i think we
do we do add value just by just by
having this meeting and
making comments on to
on to council so
i mean that's just my my personal view
of
you know being more open and a more
forensic look out there
at the mata if it comes to overview and
scrutiny first just as the general fund
and the hra plans come to
ons first and then go on to council so i
think there there is a similarity there
i mean
really those are the three places where
the big money is it's in the general
fund the hra and in cifco so i think i
think i would i would prefer to treat
them similarly ons first and then on to
council i'm going to come to councillor
busby first and then to councillor scott
far be for me to try and persuade you
one way or the other but look the
cisco's gone through two phases first of
all the growth phase which was important
and it was important that we kept a
close eye on that
second for the business plan is how we
intend now having fully
been invested to manage
those investments what are our
intentions and we've stated that fairly
clearly what our intentions are
they won't change i suspect next year or
the year after or the year after our
intentions will be very similar
i can't see the benefit of
both ons and full council looking at the
business plan
full council will get to see the
financial impact of civco as part of its
financial reporting and that's the most
important thing for the council going
forward and it will get that on a
regular basis
i'm not certain what we're going to be
able to tell you in the next 12 months
will be different from what we're going
to tell you now
and three years on what will be
different okay
maybe there's a
slight change in the debts or maybe the
profits
change but profit and losses
only occur when you actually sell or
sell the investment
it's only paper
profit and loss at the moment
i'm not certain there's a benefit
in you
doing it and for council
take the responsibility full council can
delegate to you guys
that's the reason for the whistle for
suggesting this
thank you because the scarf
um
yeah i mean i i'm still minded to say um
on this occasion send it to council
council then makes the decision as to
whether scrutiny is the scrutineer of
the business plan or council is the
scrutiny of the business plan rather
than both if that's the case but i think
by taking it to council
we enable the wider membership of the
council to decide what is the
appropriate course of action for
scrutinizing the business plan they may
well say that over they're happy with
overview and scrutiny doing it but i
think if we don't do it i this proposal
is by exception only if we if we
have a major issue with the business
plan then i think we've missed the trick
because by taking it to council council
can make that decision council can of
course reverse that decision in future
as well but it leaves it to council
which goes back to my wider point which
is a wider membership all members of
both councils get the opportunity to
make that decision if they are present
on the day so i'd be happy
i'd be happy to send it to council and
then council make the decision as to
whether
scrutiny just looks at it and just
that's it and then council gets we know
council gets the financial information
but just for count to be assured that
council on both councils are happy with
that decision let them make that
decision
i've got councillor carter and then i've
got councillor humphreys
thank you i'm fully supported for what
council scarf said about bringing the
decision to council guards we're not it
goes to overseas
here or to council decide
um
i would say
definite value coming here because
whilst the intentions might be the same
we have seen in recent years that things
can change like that world events can
have an impact and how it may it may
affect how we
have our business plan may affect other
things so it's definitely very important
to come to
a body such as
utility
we have the papers available
that come on modern gov which other
councillors can subscribe to they can
look at it
we can we can do a bit more of an effort
of going out and saying this is coming
over scrutiny i suggest you
look at this and get back to your
representatives
and people leaning on other council
councillors to
get hold of members of
of um
here or even attend in person if they
should wish to we can do a push for that
but
anyone can subscribe
anyone can see these papers
and anyone can have an impact that way
so it's very important in my opinion
that it goes to overview scrutiny and
that is that it'd be
here to look at it but by all means
bring it to council so the council can
say if they agree
with their opinion
thank you councillor humphreys mr thank
you uh councillor grandi's points were
absolutely bang on um this is the
purpose of this committee isn't it this
is what you do
and i'm not normally part of this
committee i've just come into it but i
can see what we're doing and i think
you're diligent enough to make the
decisions that have been passed down to
you from full council to be able to do
that so i don't see an issue with the
recommendation at all what i would like
to suggest though is because there is
some sort of fracture that uh the
recommendations at the moment it's all
voting on one uh maybe that 3.3 should
be a separate gen separate
recommendation
to make it clear and to stop
it contaminating the two recommendations
yeah i think it's clear we we will have
to vote on that one separately
um
does anybody else want to say anything
on on recommendation three
three
if not
then
i would suggest we look at three one and
three two because there is no reference
in those recommendations that that our
comments should go on to
council and
i think in the past
normally what we've
what we've done is to note
the trading activity and performance
um
and then the next one
we recommend that council are made aware
of the comments of this committee
so
if you're happy with
adding those two i'm not quite sure
where we are with three three whether we
put that to the vote as it stands and it
either stands or falls
um
um
or whether
the majority would seek to
wouldn't seek to amend it
um
councillor humphreys
mr chair thank you i think 3.3 stands it
is what it is you either agree that you
don't that is the recommendation and
therefore we should just clearly vote on
it
as a separate
recommendation and not change yet
if
a
thank
counselor
muller
you now i actually totally agree with um
casey humphries on that one so if he's
proposing that i'm happy to second thank
you
well we have a proposal we have a second
so we
we
can we can we take
this now as it's
or would you rather we we spent
five minutes
yeah and as far as i understood it so
far is that you would like the council
to decide that the future safeguard
business plan was scrutinized by the
council's organ security committee
is that correct
i i think what has been proposed is 3.3
exactly as
as it's typed here
um i i mean i get the feeling that there
there's quite a bit of dissension from
that
but
that's been proposed it's been seconded
we can't have another proposal until we
voted on that one i think we should take
that vote in separately
and um if that is if it is carried that
we carry it forward to council if it's
rejected then we'll need to come up with
something else right so shall we
counselor grant uh
can i just um could you just before we
do that um clarify i think other
counselors want that as well to clarify
then exactly what we're voting for
if
if we've you know when we come to voting
for
um item 3.3 that if we vote for it are
we voting then that it doesn't
that
that
in future it's only ons is that correct
and doesn't go to council can you
clarify that well
yeah i think there is a bit of
clarification needed here because we
can't decide that in future
the sifko plans are
scrutinized by us only i think it's the
council have got to decide that so we
what we can do is to recommend to
council that in future
as it says in 3.3
so
i don't think we can
um
this is getting really complicated i
mean
we've got a proposal and we've got a
second
to do something that we can't do so
that's i mean that that's put us in a
difficult position to start off with
if
if what you if what the proposal and the
secondary intent is that we recommend
to council that the in future cifco
business plans
are only reported to council if the
committee is not satisfied
um then i think that would be reasonable
am i right
that would be reasonable
i mean we don't know whether it's going
to be
carried or not can i just say so what
scrutiny you're doing are you we need
your views really on the business plan
has been approved by the holding
companies and we seek the council's
joint overview
committee to consider whether the
current performance of cisco delivers
good value to the councils
the kpis are appropriate measures of
performance
the business plan is robust and
appropriate for the next 12 months and
there is sufficient confidence in the
management of cifco so that's the first
thing you need to
agree on
and then you need to agree whether
you're going to recommend to council
that you
um review
as a committee this disco plan um and
only recommend to council
if um
you um have concerns that you need to to
say that you that's what you want to
recommend to council or that you
recommend that overview and scrutiny
still scrutinize it and send it on to
council so they're the two options
you're going to recommend to council so
either one or the other
right
i think i understand
councillor osborne
thank you mr chairman yes i tend to
agree with councillor busby and
councillor hump um solid councillor
humphreys and and councillor muller and
and i cannot see
you know as
councillor busby has pointed out you
have got a situation that could arise
next year could be in the next three
years so this is the place for it but i
can't see the point of actually having
to discuss this on a full council as
catherine uh councillor grandin has
pointed out it it becomes
a word shot and
quite honestly
we have a lot of other things involved
with with the councils as councillor
busby has pointed out so
if that could be clarified exactly where
it's going to go because i don't
personally want to see it go back to to
a full council meeting after it's been
made
and the presentation by by sifko has
been excellent i can't see the point of
all of that going round in circles
thank you
right
shall we put to one side i i
asked
my colleagues here can we put to one
side 3.1.3.2
for the minute and can we
can would it then be appropriate to vote
on 3.3 and then come back to 3.1 or 3.2
and
i will attempt to read out what i think
3.3 years
and that is that
overview and scrutiny committee
recommend to full council that
as in 3.3 this is now pacifico business
plans are scrutinized by the council's
joint overview scrutiny committee
and only reported to council if the
committee is not satisfied with the
company's business plan and performance
chair and if you take a vote on that
obviously if if it's voted down then
we'll just default back to how it is at
the moment
you won't recommend to council you
you'll recommend the existing
arrangements stick to cancer yeah yeah
but but we
we'll have to we'll have to come forward
with a new proposal if we're going to do
that exactly exactly
so is is that no that is in the blue box
chair that boat is now in progress
it's stupid
counselor carter can i take your vote
verbally
okay
chair that's five bytes four and six
again so that's lost
okay
thank you so
we now have to come up with something
which
um
is almost
i guess is almost the opposite of that
so chair we could just agree to keep the
status quo
recommend to council that the um
scrutiny arrangements are kept as is
counselor hinton
if i can make some suggestions if you
look at the wording that we've just been
voting on if we then say that the
overview and scrutiny committee
recommends to full council that future
cifco business plans are scrutinized by
the council's joint overview and
scrutiny committee
and then reported to full council full
stop
i would suggest we continue to be
scrutinized by joint overview of
scrutiny because they are already
so it's in other words maintaining we
need to put it in words
yeah yeah maintaining the status quo
putting it in words
if that's what if that's if that is a
proposal
yes do i have a seconder
councillor dawson ii did that
so
so
why are you having to maintain
[Music]
chairman the recommendations in the
papers
all talk about the council notes cifco's
doesn't mention overview and scrutiny at
all the only time overview and scrutiny
gets mentioned is it was in 3-3 which
has just been lost it doesn't say
anything about status quos either we
have to come up with a recommendation on
the papers not
i mean it's a valid it's a valid
proposal it's been seconded
um
i'll tell a couple of speakers because
we really have had this debate through
and through
um
councillor caston
and i think i saw councillor scarf and
then councillor carter and then then
we'll take the vote
the um i'm hoping this doesn't turn into
too much of a case in point of um why
going through too many committee
meetings takes up people's time and
everything
what we have now is after that um
vote that proposal failed we have a very
clear indicator
of the way the committee feels about it
um
i think if we give this
if we give that
um that failed proposal over with the
amount of votes each way that's the
clearest indicator we can possibly have
of the recommendations to scrutiny um
changing the wording and going back will
just give us
six five the other way it's completely
pointless and we don't vote to maintain
the status quo we vote to change it so
in this point we will go back to the
state the status quo because it failed
chair we do need to deal with it because
you've had a proposal a second year
you've got a motion in front of you you
do need to vote on it but just just
another word of course you are just
recommend you know you're giving your
recommendations to counsel at the end of
the day council may choose to disregard
your recommendations
of this proposal is that it will be in
front of council who will need to make a
decision
yeah
uh so i've got councillor scarf and then
councillor
carter yeah thank you chad i mean i
think the important thing is that
council makes the decision about who
scrutinizes the business plan and
without sending it to council council
can't make that decision so therefore
the proposal now to send it to council
they can then adjust it if they feel
it's appropriate if they feel it's
inappropriate that they still want to
look at it as well as overview and
scrutiny it's then a decision of all
members of both councils
council carter
i think having her to cancel a scarf
explain it now i've
got the grass but my budget before i was
having
spasms and i was trying to work out
by
going against the previous vote does it
mean they have to have a whole
presentation to counsel again but as
we're looking at just
council deciding that we remain as
everyone scrutiny looking at it
it was i was it was i was spinning so i
think i've got the grasp of it
i hope
right
if this one fails then we don't we don't
actually pass anything on to
any recommendation one way or the other
on to council
[Laughter]
well
yes it's a blue one so
this one is that the overview and
scrutiny committee recommended for
council that future
sifko business plans continue to be
scrutinized by the council's joint
overview and scrutiny committee and then
reported to council
proposal and secondary is that precisely
what you had in mind
okay we will vote on that then
chair that break is now in progress
chair that's six weights four four four
against and one abstention so that's
correct thank you very much
um
right so we if we go back to 3.1 and 3.2
do we need are we are we sufficiently
clear on what we've been voting for in
3.1 and 3.2 that we don't need to take a
break
chair i made up a few one and two
recommendations um beforehand um
beforehand just now when you were
talking and i suggest that the first
recommendation is that the joint
overview and scrutiny notes specifical
business plan and business trading and
performance and ask that the minutes of
this meeting
be taken into account at full council
and uh number 1.2 that the joint
overview and scrutiny committee is
satisfied that the difficult business
plan and business trading and
performance issues for 2022 and 2023
are we content to vote on that on those
two they're two separate recommendations
two separate
so are we content to vote on both of
those we'll take them one at a time
you don't need them to relay that again
do you
please
okay
so
um
there'll be some
chair would you need them in modern.gov
app or our members happy with the ones i
just read out to you aloud
i think
i think
if we just have coming up in bright blue
on here
as as as read out by the senior
governance
we we would all be content with that
yeah thank you
do we have a proposal sector for this
please
there were so many hands went up i think
i think council grandin was first and
councilor carter was second
um
and we're not going to have a fight
about who proposed and then seconded
right it's there in blue now give the
other votes now in progress
chair that's 11 votes for that so that's
unanimous and that's carried
now i think that we've covered
everything that we were expecting to
cover in terms of cifco
yeah
there is a bit of discussion as to
whether we have actually covered
everything that we need to cover so
emily has just asked if we can cover
this statement in 2.2 because although
that last recommendation um
did cover um the majority it she wants
it specifically covered that the
business plan has been approved by the
holding companies and seek the council's
joint overview and scrutiny to consider
whether the current performance pacifico
delivers good value to the councils the
kpis are appropriate measures of
performance
the business plan is robust and
appropriate for the next 12 months and
there is sufficient confidence in the
management of cifco
so we can do this two ways we can say
that
that
the vote that you've just taken
incorporates that or we can now do the
vote on what that statement says in 2.2
you're two here
so this this is do we want to vote on
whether or not we
accept agree and pass on to council
everything that's in paragraph 2.2 not
in the recommendations box but in
paragraph 2.2 on page 11 or are we
content that
the
what has been already agreed
is sufficient
counselor casting
i think to if it needs to be robust i'm
quite happy to propose
that we agree to all of those
statement in 2.2 yeah all of the
statements in 2.2
can we have a second of that then thank
you councillor humphreys
and then we'll just set that up as a
vote and make sure
that in
paragraph
yes
council humphreys might have your vote
verbally please four okay
chair that's eleven bites before so
that's unanimous
thank you very much
i think we have now covered everything
that we can possibly cover on on sifko
that being the case can i thank you all
for coming along
um
sorry it took so long but i think we've
got there in the end
um
and we have another couple of items if
you want to
creep out oh stay
shall we or do you think we can run
through
i don't think it will take long
i think the rest of the agenda there are
only another four items i think
they should be fairly quick are you
content that we don't take a break and
we we finish
you want a break facility
all right
five five five minutes maximum
we're now going to move on to item
8 which is the action tracker it's on
page 63.
it is for noting
are there any comments from members i
think it's very useful to have this
um
and
it is only for noting so
we move we move on if there are no
comments
the forthcoming decisions list
um
hopefully members will have had an
opportunity to look at the forthcoming
decisions list
are there any comments anything that you
want lifting from the forthcoming
decisions list
to come to joint overview and scrutiny
as there are none
thank you the forthcoming decisions list
is for noting
items 10 and 11 which perhaps we can
take together
they are the
weber overview and scrutiny
committee
work plan and the mid-suffolk
overview and scrutiny committee work
plan
they are pretty nearly identical
because most of the meetings are planned
to be joint meetings
um
so
is there anything
that anybody wants to say
on the the work plans
no
counselor hinton
thanks chairman i just
say that uh repeat what i said at the
last council meeting and there are
several issues that uh i think overview
and scrutiny
favor inverted commerce
should be looking at whether minster
wants to look at them as well that would
be entirely up to them really um coming
forward
but i will discuss those with the
officers outside of the meeting rather
than put them forward now for a work
plan
yes
there will be an opportunity on
if it
will probably be the 18th of july
instead of having a formal meeting
there'll be an informal meeting to go
through the feedback that officers have
put together from the previous informal
meeting uh anything that that comes out
of the chairs and vice chairs briefing
tomorrow and anything that
any member of overview and scrutiny and
indeed any member of either council
wishes to put forward
they can all go into the melting pot and
hopefully
but at the end of that informal session
on the 18th of july there will be
a
a plan
for each of the each of the councils and
would it be possible that that time also
to decide at that informal session
which will be joint
meetings because i think
what we
one of the problems we've had in the
past is that we've gone forward with
two separate dates
in the work plans and then normally then
when one has be when when they've become
joint meetings one of those dates has
been cancelled and the other and for
those people that district
uh their members
they've got a different date in the
diary they had
you know they had to kept the thursday
free but they find that the meeting is
now a joint meeting is on the following
monday
so it might be
it might be good to sort that out as
soon as possible for the for the whole
year
yeah really good idea yes yeah we can
take that forward to that meeting
so
uh that being the case i anticipate that
that that informal meeting will be held
on the 18th of july i think we probably
need to to just make sure of
availability because
we need to have as many people as
possible
at that meeting although it's an
informal meeting it is a is as in as
important as a formal meeting because
it's going to set the whole
work plan for the whole year
so
gasoline is thinking physical or
electronic i was teams off in here in
the chamber
i would i would anticipate it would be a
physical meeting i think he needs to be
face to face in order to have
a reasonable discussion
um yeah
i think that would be best
okay that being the case then that
concludes this meeting thank you very
much
you